I started my business in South Central
Los Angeles in the hood before the world
called me the dog whisperer I was called
a Mexican guy who can walk a pack of
dogs so I started walking dogs literally
and because it's a necessity that I saw
that it was more important for the dog
than training the dog if a dog is tired
by walking him he won't give you a
problem if a dog is trained he still
gives you a problem sit down stay come
here doesn't get rid of the problem
tiredness gets the energy so get rid of
the energy because the tired of would
never get in trouble walk us through how
did you know you had this gift I mean a
dog whisperer it's significantly bigger
than a guy than a Mexican guy who walks
dogs yeah well it's because obviously
they can call me the Mexican guy on
television embrace it but the whisper
part becomes more magical you know for
for the viewers and where'd you get the
magic from it's instincts it's for
world's instinctual world intellectual
world emotional world spiritual world so
I teach people they live in this world
like they said my dog is very smart but
he doesn't come when I call him my dog
is my baby but he wants to attack a dog
my dog is my soul my baby doesn't like
my husband see they come from this
perception so what I teach is
instinctual world common sense so your
new show is called Cesar 9-1-1 NatGeo
i'm gonna pull up some pictures of my
dog Steve here and I have always wanted
your help Steve's about four years old
and ever since he started ever since you
turned 2 or adolescent he started to
attack other dogs like I wish Cesar was
here I could send Steve to him can I
call Cesar 911 now it's dedicated right
there that's what's important yeah he
just said not Steve the opportunity that
you uncovered that you need to train
people not dogs correct because dog
trainers were already established and so
it's already so people send dogs to the
dog trainer and the dog behaves good for
the dog trainer but not the human so you
pretty much just throw your money right
right so I said look let me let me help
Americans to invest the money right so
that way they actually become educated
and see that's an investment not not
just that expense so I I mean I know
it's me because I've watched every
single episode of your show and you
always say training people not the dog
what about business opportunities for
you beyond you sell you sell dog
accoutrement you sell your show you have
opened another dog psychology center in
Florida what else is out there for
Caesar what they chose in 120 countries
so pretty much the whole entire world is
my dog park yeah are you gonna would you
open this a dog I'm going daycare camps
you know well I think the education is
first before you actually tell the
person what they need like grooming and
this and that because a lot of people
don't know how to be with a dog so
that's what we business number number
one and that's something that nobody has
ever taught and the whole entire you
know history of humans and dogs the pet
industry is pegged at being a fifty
eight billion dollar industry at least
that number right this it's a dog as a
child right so once you want to make
sure that your loved ones are well taken
care of then why do we have more dogs in
shelters today than ever before
because the human doesn't follow through
you know his human is not very committed
in a relationship that he starts so he
looks for for excuses to get rid of the
dog it says something about the dog I'm
gonna get another dog you've met with
loads of celebrity pet owners dog lovers
who's the best dog owner from the
celebrity set well they're all are I
mean they're all powerful famous and
everything who's a great dog owner is it
Oprah no I will say Jada pinkett-smith
really comes through as a pack of dogs
yeah girl she's tiny but she's powerful